tenemos nueve estudiantes que se acaban
de graduar de una muy pequeña escuela
toda la generación consiste de nueve
personas y queremos averiguar cuál es la
tendencia central de los salarios un año
después de su graduación claro que
también nos interesa tener una idea de
cuál es la dispersión alrededor de esa
tendencia central todos los alumnos de
esa generación aceptaron ingresar en una
computadora sus salarios y los podemos
ver aquí ahora no es que estén ganando
35 pesos al mes aquí lo que tenemos son
cuántos miles de pesos ganan al semestre
así es que esta persona gana 35 mil
pesos al semestre está gana 50 mil 50
mil 50 mil 56 mil 60 mil 60 mil 75 mil y
a esta persona le va muy bien y gana 250
mil pesos al semestre ahora
ya con todos estos datos la computadora
arroja estos parámetros nos da dos
medidas distintas de la tendencia
central y dos medidas distintas de la
dispersión por aquí tenemos la media que
es aproximadamente 70 y 6.2 la
calculadora calcula la media que es
aproximadamente 76 punto 2 sumando todos
los valores y dividiéndolo entre el
número de datos que tenemos en este caso
es 9 y por acá tenemos la mediana que es
56 la cual es mucho más fácil de
calcular lo único que tenemos que hacer
es ordenar los datos y encontrar cuál es
el del medio que en este caso es 56
ahora lo que yo quiero que hagas en este
vídeo es que le pongas una pausa y
pienses en cuál de estas dos medidas de
tendencia central es la más apropiada
para estos datos que tenemos aquí pero
bueno vamos a graficar por aquí todos
estos datos
para tener una mejor idea de cómo se
relacionan entre sí por aquí digamos que
tenemos el 0 así es que por acá tenemos
250 tenemos 50
150 200 y 250 y luego queremos dividir
esto más por aquí está el 60 70 80 y 90
y aproximadamente por acá está el 40 y
el 30 y el 20 y el 10 me pudo haber
quedado mejor esta escala pero vamos a
dejarlo así y vamos a graficar estos
datos uno de los estudiantes gana 35 mil
al semestre entonces tenemos un dato que
se encuentra por acá luego tenemos 3
estudiantes que ahora ganan 50 mil 123
uno de ellos gana 56 mil otros dos
estudiantes ganan 60 mil al semestre
otro estudiante gana 75 mil 50 60 70 75
está más o menos por aquí
y finalmente un estudiante gana 250.000
al semestre o sea que lo grafica mos por
acá pero entonces si calculamos la media
de 76.2 eso es más o menos por acá así
es que aquí nos tenemos que preguntar si
esta es una buena medida de la tendencia
central bueno pues a mí no me parece que
sea una buena medida de tendencia
central porque esa medida de tendencia
central es mayor que casi todos los
datos de la muestra es mayor que todos
excepto uno y la razón por la que sucede
esto es que la medida está siendo muy
sesgada por un solo dato que es mucho
más grande que el resto de los datos
este dato de 250.000 al semestre está
demasiado alejado del resto de los datos
por lo que está influyendo demasiado
sobre la media y este es un fenómeno que
podemos encontrar bastante seguido
cuando tenemos por ejemplo los salarios
de algunas personas si muchos datos se
encuentran por acá entre sí
cuenta 35 o 60 75 pero con un dato que
se encuentre excesivamente alejado del
resto de los datos una persona que esté
ganando 250 mil modifica demasiado la
media hace que sea una media sesgada
porque aquí estamos sumando todos estos
valores y dividiendo los entre el número
de valores sumados por eso es por lo que
influye tanto y en este tipo de casos
donde tenemos valores que podrían
modificar demasiado a la media la mejor
medida de tendencia central es la
mediana la mediana 56 está justo en este
lugar y es una medida de tendencia
central mucho mejor porque por ejemplo
si esta persona en lugar de ganar 250
mil al semestre ganará no sé por ejemplo
250 millones al semestre la mediana
seguiría estando en este lugar
tras que la media aumentaría muchísimo
estaría muy sesgada a esta media por
este valor pero la mediana se quedaría
en exactamente el mismo lugar porque a
la mediana no le importa qué tan grande
es este número podría ser 250 y 100
ceros a la derecha de todas formas la
mediana se va a quedar en este mismo
lugar por lo que la mediana es una
medida mucho más robusta una mucho mejor
medida de tendencia central si tenemos
datos que no son simétricos si tenemos
datos que se alejan mucho del resto de
los datos la media es una muy buena
medida si tienes datos más o menos
simétricos datos en los que más o menos
la mitad está abajo y la otra mitad está
arriba y no tenemos este tipo de datos
que están demasiado sesgados en alguna
dirección y claro esto se vuelve más
importante si tenemos sólo unos cuantos
datos como es el caso
si es que en este ejemplo la mediana es
una mejor medida de tendencia central
pero también nos falta preguntarnos qué
pasa con la dispersión y bueno en estos
momentos tú me puedes decir oye sal pero
nos acabas de explicar que la media no
es una muy buena medida en este ejemplo
y la desviación estándar se deriva a
partir de la media para calcular esta
desviación estándar lo que hacemos es
tomar cada uno de estos datos restarle
el valor de la media ya esa resta
elevarla al cuadrado y sumamos cada una
de esas restas elevadas al cuadrado
luego como estamos tomando la desviación
estándar tenemos que dividir entre el
número de datos que tenemos y a todo eso
le sacamos la raíz cuadrada así es que
como la desviación estándar está basada
en la media y acabamos de ver que en
este ejemplo la media no es una muy
buena medida esas mismas razones van a
hacer que la desviación estándar esté
muy sesgada que no represente de una
buena
lo que está pasando en este ejemplo este
valor la desviación estándar es mucho
más grande que lo que esperaríamos de un
indicador de dispersión es cierto
tenemos por aquí este valor que está muy
alejado de la media y también de la
mediana pero el resto de los datos se
encuentran bastante cerca entre sí y
bastante cerca de la mediana así es que
para este ejemplo no solo vamos a usar
la mediana sino que también vamos a usar
el rango inter cuartil como medida de
dispersión y como encontramos el rango
inter cuartil bueno pues encontramos el
primer cuartil y el tercer cuartel ahora
para encontrar el primer cuartil tomamos
el bloque de datos que son menores que
la mediana de la muestra y encontramos
su mediana que en este caso es 50 y
luego por acá el tercer cuartel es la
mediana del bloque de datos mayores a la
mediana de la muestra por aquí tenemos
60 y 75
entonces la mediana de este grupo es
67.5 y listo la resta es el rango inter
cuartil ahora si alguna de estas cosas
no te pareció completamente clara
tenemos muchos vídeos acerca de cómo
calcular la media la desviación estándar
la mediana el rango inter cuartil y
todos los cuartiles y en esos otros
vídeos lo vemos con mucho detalle aquí
simplemente estamos haciendo un repaso
pero bueno la diferencia entre estos dos
es 17.5 así es que ese es nuestro rango
inter cuartil ahora aquí es una muy
buena idea observar que este rango inter
cuartil esta distancia de 17.5 no cambia
por más que modifiquemos este valor de
250 así es que estas dos medidas la
mediana y el rango inter cuartil son las
medidas más robustas si tenemos un
conjunto de datos que está un poco
sesgado lo que podemos concluir aquí es
que la media y la desviación estándar
no son malas medidas si tenemos un
conjunto de datos que es más o menos
simétrico y si no tenemos datos muy
atípicos datos que van a sesgar la media
y la desviación estándar en esas
condiciones la media y la desviación
estándar pueden ser medidas muy útiles
en esas buenas condiciones la media y la
desviación estándar son medidas muy
sólidas sin embargo si tenemos un
conjunto de datos con datos que son tan
atípicos como este y si tenemos tan
poquitos datos la mediana y el rango
inter cuartil son medidas mucho más
útiles la mediana como medida de
tendencia central y el rango inter
cuartil como medida de dispersión
alrededor de esa tendencia central y es
por este tipo de razones por las que
generalmente usamos la mediana y el
rango inter cuartil cuando estamos
hablando de salarios porque muchas veces
tenemos valores atípicos y lo mismo
sucede cuando estamos hablando de
precios de casas de alguna zona
generalmente usamos la mediana y no
media porque en una colonia podemos
tener casas de dos millones o de tres
millones pero puede ser que justo haya
alguna mansión en medio de la colonia y
que esa mansión valga como 100 millones
y si calculamos la media de los valores
de las casas en esa colonia la media por
esa mansión va a subir muchísimo
dándonos una falsa impresión del precio
que tienen generalmente las casas en esa
colonia dándonos una mayor tendencia
central de lo que cuestan las casas en
esa colonia